[Music]
so my mom
she's been married three times she just
goes from boyfriend to boyfriend she
likes to spend time with my two-year-old
which is which is great but the
boyfriend is always around in some way
either he lives there or she has to do
something nope
i'll solve that one for you answer's no
[Music]
good morning wherever you happen to be
this is john the dr john deloney show
i guess i said she said good morning to
you good morning to your family
and i hope you're doing well wherever
you happen to be i conflated those two
my wife often says john it's a lot of
pronouns i don't know what you're
talking about don't know what you're
talking about you combine sentences i
don't think i just did that there so
quick slap it up flip it reverse it good
morning hope you're doing well hope your
family's well i hope your mental health
is well hope your relationships are well
and if they're not that's what we are
here for to walk alongside you and help
figure out what the next right crooked
thing to do is
let's go right to the phones let's go to
maria and tampa what's up maria
hi how are we doing
i am just so excited and very very
grateful yeah i'm excited thank you so
much for your time no i'm good grief
i'm so grateful for you you're too kind
so what's up
okay i am
super displeased with the way that i am
managing my disordered eating and
maintaining my sobriety
hmm
walk me through it tell me more
so in the process of trying to frame up
my question neatly which is
kind of difficult
distorted eating and addiction are never
never uh
summed up neatly so give me the whole
messy mess
okay so i first of all am a mom i have
three kids five and under so i am in
just the best season of life
um this is true i am not being sarcastic
okay um
okay so i have racing thoughts it feels
like
multiple trains of thoughts
zipping by in different directions super
fast super loud all the time in my head
and it all seems very urgent like needs
to be thought of right now
past present future to-do list shame all
of it at one time all the time and i
don't know how to
step out of that turn it down dismiss
the thoughts
um i also
uh
like i never
i had a really chaotic childhood and so
like the binge purge thing made a lot of
sense for
a while for me because it just was like
a semblance of control in my life
um but i
don't know how to take care of myself is
what it comes down to like i i do not
know how to relax so that i might enjoy
my body and my brain um and i'm just
like i'm not having a good time and
i'm gonna be bold and say i deserve to
be having a good time
[Applause]
this is literally exactly the life that
i've always wanted and i find myself
constantly dysregulated angry agitated
short tempered and therefore everyone
around me experiences that too yep
god you mean
yeah
yeah i i don't i got more but no i know
you do
um
you're just incredible let me just say
that all right and
not enough people tell you that and i'm
grateful you you have an ability to
you've been to counseling before
yes and
attempts to
overcome what was just like a lot of
disconnection
my mom put me in in treatment patients
like five times and it never for eating
because it wasn't the problem i also was
suicidal like i just needed like a hug i
think and
nobody knew that or like understood that
and so after
um i moved out and like started living
my life with my like now husband i
realized i have a level of
responsibility to cultivate my mind and
my body and my lifestyle
and so i am super informed
but i have it is extremely
difficult for me to apply
any of the nerd things that i know a lot
about
and i am so frustrated i'm so
and and i'm a i'm a perfectionist and so
i'm like
super full of shame
and guilt like all the time yeah um okay
the reason i asked if you've been in
counseling was
you have a
you're years down the road towards being
well and i know you don't realize that
your ability to see
from an elevated position both what's
going on and you're
putting some distance between your
response to what's going on and your
ability to point at all right here's
where it is and i don't i don't
i see i hear the the engine knocking
right here right your ability to do that
is
light years ahead of most people i talk
to good for you like i i want you to
know the work you've put in has not been
wasted okay
um
the word that keeps coming to mind as
you're talking is a it's a scary word
okay
um for a couple of different reasons but
the word that keeps coming to mind is
exhaustion
dude i have a four-month-old and a
two-year-old and a five-year-old and
they're all in my bed and
and more than that
um your body's been in fight or flight
for about 30 years right yeah yeah and
so there's a point when you keep
adding in the quote-unquote right things
i crossed the finish line i got the life
i wanted you overcame so many odds
to get where you're to achieve what
you've achieved and to
cross the finish lines you've crossed
can we recognize that it's incredible
thank you for saying that the the the
professionals who were around you when
you were 14
would have looked at just an actuarial
table and said
this is probably not likely where you've
landed
and it's a testament to
strength and grit and you've probably
got chewed off broken fingernails
because you've scratched and clawed your
way to this point you had a picture in
your head and you will achieve this is
am i right
and you found a guy tell me about him is
he awesome
he is awesome equally uh crazy but we
have
just we found each other
uh
like super young and have been together
ever since we've been together
for 10 years and we
you know like on paper i've done
everything the right way like we dated
for a few years and we were married for
a year and then we started having babies
and we're starting our own company and i
mean lots of really great things but um
he also
did not receive i mean i guess just
proper instruction for a living
love and just like basic things yeah but
we're just figuring it out together and
we kind of take turns being
the likes like i don't know more stable
one more mature one okay so just grow
together
so
you've done all the right stuff
the one giant glaring omission
that i think is the hardest thing to do
is you have not
made peace with maria
and you have run from what maria was
you've run from the hell that was your
childhood and you say chaotic i'm
calling bs on that you've had some
you've seen some stuff fair
yes sir okay um
you
you haven't made peace with maria
and because you haven't made peace and i
i'm like i'm at you right imagine me and
you having chips and salsa right and
like you know i don't know if you're
sober but we're having a drink we're
hanging out okay your husband's hanging
out and we're just chilling so i'm not
i'm not getting on to i'm just telling
you
until you let maria
go
maria
nine years old maria 14 years old maria
4 is still fighting on your behalf
because there's still a mom that no
matter what the hell you do you cannot
make her get off your back
and then she tries to solve it by
sending you away from her right
am i on to it you still there
yeah yeah
am i right tell me i'm wrong no you're
so right she just like it feels bad
because i know no no no don't don't
defend her she's right no excuses yeah
she's a grown-up she's a grown-up you
don't have to defend her right now yep
she didn't know though that's okay
but it doesn't minimize the hurt
right so true yeah no it still hurts
what about dad where was dad
well they got a divorce when i was three
they co-parent no not well we saw him
about every other weekend and then
because my brother and i are close in
age and then uh when i was probably
12 my brother moved out to live with him
and i pretty much stopped all contact
like he stopped talking to me i stopped
talking to him we never saw each other
until i had my first kid that was like
five years ago so
it's never
and there's a three to 12 year old maria
continuing to continuing to ask herself
what could i have done differently to
keep this thing together
how could i have acted a little bit
different so that dad would come around
a little bit more
and then they took your lifeline away
which is your brother
and then at 12 years old you found
yourself responsible for mom's
emotional stability
fair
yeah
if i say this mom flies off the handle
so i need to make sure that i don't say
this i don't eat this i don't do this i
need to clamp down on everything i can
control because if i don't mom fill in
the blank
fair yeah
that's an exhausted nine-year-old little
girl
and so running from and again can i tell
you i do
my my family situation is different but
the sprinting and i recognize this in
the mirror okay so i feel like i'm
talking to myself here
i sprinted so hard to show with my
income and my job title and the
university i worked for and my two
healthy little kids and my pretty wife
that i could get all the stuff
and my body was still
swinging and kicking and running and
hiding
as it had been since i was a little
little little
and so the work now is less perfection
and
this stuff gets more sophisticated
and so as you have you started have you
started binging again
um i
binge i find that it's like yes but not
as frequently by any means but it's like
when i'm particularly tired particularly
frustrated
um
like i
am just in the middle of
all of these kids and everybody's
screaming and instead of screaming or
like wanting to drink i might just go
eat a whole box of money bars and pop
trash and a bag of stomach uh
gummy sour gummy worms oh my gosh you
just you just said all my things yes
they are my favorite and i can't have
them in the house because it's like
what is self-control is that a thing
listen
i was i was on the phone with my doctor
again this weekend dr vickery i think
he's one of the greatest doctors in the
united states of america and he told me
as a reminder he saw my blood work and
i've got it out of the house for x
number of months now
and he said
i have never like i my triglycerides
have dropped my my all sorts of metrics
i don't want to geek out but he said as
a reminder you can't have these in your
house based on your genetic profile
right so but let's back out so yes
you're right it just is and it stinks
and i hate it and that's that's that's
the cards we've been dealt right um
some people look like brad pitt some
people look like me right and that's
just the cards i got dealt and so i just
have to know
um
but let's back out for a second
can we get real graphic is that cool
yeah please like all the yes when you
throw up
and your stomach rolls it's rolling over
that hill
and you get to the point where it starts
taking on it it starts doing it itself
and your
core tightens up a lot and then it
relaxes and tightens up relaxes and your
tears come because just because it's
your body working so hard
there is a complete and total
when that's over right a release
am i right
yes yeah
that's your body
at your head in your mind
trying to find ways that it can go
whoosh
like why not just go take a walk like
how come i cannot
like i am because your body is a dark
person maria maria
your body's at war
your body's a war
and as
what age were you when the first time
well i won't pre i'm pretty sure i'm
right
what was the age somebody hurt you
i cannot remember okay
before 12 or after 12 or both
before and after but i subjected myself
after as a teenager nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope
[Music]
no if i would have just said those words
to my own kid like that would have been
the most messed up thing like i did not
subject myself to anything as a kid i
was taken advantage of it's not
supervised that's right
and
you're continuing
continuing to tell 14 year old maria 17
year old maria who was desperate for
someone to look at her and say you're
worthy even for 30 minutes
you're desperate for somebody to say no
you're worth you're worth being around
on my terms but you're worth being
around right do you see what i'm saying
here's what i'm trying to i'm just
trying to draw a thread here
to an
incredible mother
and a woman of strength you have no idea
how strong you are
the amount of energy you and your body
put forth every day to hold back the
tsunami
is
something that most of us walking
through life have absolutely no idea
and the greatest gift you can give
yourself is to put your arms down and
let the water run because it'll drain
out
and your body will no sleep and your
body will know intentionality and then
you'll have actual
you'll have strength for willpower and
this is all
neuroscientist isn't just like woo-woo
like
how
like like literally what do i do to do
that i am
here's what you got to do you've got to
go enter into a therapeutic relationship
with somebody with one goal in mind
not to stop a behavior
but to make peace with maria
keep these words in your mind you have
to let that little girl go play
and right now she's fighting off an
uncle she's fighting off
your brother's friends she's fighting
off high school she's fighting off mom
she's fighting off
dad what was it about me
why'd y'all take my brother from me
and then all of the decisions that you
make right the the the band-aids that we
use
drink this
sleep with him
do this
snort that all of those things are
a brain saying somebody freaking connect
with me
and now you're a mother with a beautiful
family by the way you're in the middle
of a blender you know that right
yeah and that's like i want to enjoy it
and i want them to enjoy it and your
brains get got increasingly
sophisticated modes of trying to take
care of you
when you were a kid it was
behavior a and action b and action c
now your brain is going to just run and
run and run and run trying to get your
attention and occasionally it'll build
up and build up and build up like an
itch you can't scratch until you just
eat everything and then throw up and get
that complete and utter
and then you can start building it back
up again
you have to have to have to do two
things you got to go get into into a
therapeutic relationship you got to call
somebody
okay and let them know i've built it
back i'm
i'll storm the gates of hell with my
strength i'm strong
and i'm ready to heal
and the second thing you're gonna have
to do which my guess is you don't have
is you're gonna have to get a couple of
women in your life that you trust that
become your friends have you ever done
that
no
my guess is you are lonely lonely lonely
and you have the picture of everything
that looks good but your body is
screaming where are my friends
yes
stuff here
okay those two things
please are you hearing me i tell you how
what
just
great aba you are you get that
i hear you it's really impressive
they'll work forward now like we have to
talk to some people like in in the gym
um who work out too much like
professional athletes who work out too
hard
is i'm gonna have to train you i'm gonna
teach you how to rest
how to back it down that's where you are
is yes so that's like a therapist that's
exactly right and you have to be willing
to do
hard now
that sounds so mean i know maria
you're gonna have to be willing to
walk through some old memories that
you've your body's protecting you from
you're gonna have to walk through some
real anger towards your dad and some
real anger towards your mom even though
you love him
you're gonna have to walk through some
real
forgiveness and peace for your 14 15 17
22 25 year old self
because that beautiful little girl was
just trying to find connection and i
don't i don't blame her for a second
she's a kid
and you're gonna have to
come to terms own if you will you're
gonna have to own what happened when
you're a little little girl because that
crap shouldn't happen either
you are brave and strong and you've done
all this work leading up to right now
and now is when you jump off the deep
end with the help of a professional and
we're gonna go get well in about six
months in about nine months i want you
to call me back
because my guess is you're gonna put on
about four or five pounds of muscle
you're gonna smile and you're gonna be
laughing and you're gonna be saying oh
my because you still got three kids
under five
but it's gonna be different air that
you're breathing so so proud of you
hang on the line i'm gonna send you a
copy of on your past change your future
i want you to read it
and internalize it even take it to the
therapist with you and say it's time
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john dolone show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
deloney all right we're back let's go to
david in richmond virginia what's up
d-money
hey what's going on dr john just rocking
on to the break of dawn my brother
what's up i hear you man um i'm trying
to see if you can point me in the right
direction of
establishing some boundaries between
work
relationships and with my wife and just
trying to
find some direction man
so i work from home i run my own
business
and
i feel that
right now it's kind of difficult because
i am here all day long my wife's a
stay-at-home mom with our eight months
old
so
it's like i'm accessible i'm available
all the time but
if i'm available all the time i can't
work and make money can't make money
can't pay bills
have you all sat down while i'm reaching
out no it's i mean what you're
experiencing i've heard all over the
country for the last especially last few
years man and so hey no you're not alone
a b no
there is some
some pretty clear path forward okay
um
have you had that conversation with her
yes
it didn't go well huh
uh it really uh
it really doesn't okay tell me about it
well you know i just i sat down with her
and i said honey um
you know i'm i'm trying to
provide for the family i'm trying to get
us out of
your parents house and trying to help
our future grow you live with your
parents you live with your in-laws
yes so
just a little uh quick synopsis is
i had a job opportunity
in florida
so i established a connection down there
and i told this person hey you know if
everything is serious then i'll pursue
it he said yep everything's good
so i quit my job i was running my side
business
and i quit my full-time job sold the
house we planned to live with my in-laws
for a month or so
until we could find a place down there
move down there and start up down there
well he called me after i quit my job
and said hey
this opportunity
has come and gone with another person
filling that role oh man
all right
here we are so you moved how long have
you all been in your mother-in-law's
house
uh we've been here since december so
four or five months is she pumping your
wife full of well he should be
or is it a good place to be
it's it's not a bad place to be
there's some negativity just with their
personality types
well just sleeping with your wife in her
parents house is weird man you know i
mean like that's just strange
do you have kids too
yes we have eight months old oh my gosh
okay
so tell me what an like what a normal
well let me back up
you had this conversation you said hey
i'm trying to i need to put some put
some boundaries around my work day and
she said no
she said no
well she said
she told me i'm i'm trying to
stay out of your hair i'm trying to let
you be out there let you work
i don't know if the fact that i get up
at
four o'clock every morning and come out
here and work before her and our
daughter gets up
if that's taking a toll on her you know
not waking up beside her
that kind of stuff i don't know and then
staying out here until five o'clock in
the evening
i don't know if it's
she just misses me throughout the day
um
kind of cool if she did right yeah i
mean and it is i
i think it's great that you know we have
that connection where she does miss me
throughout the day
so i'm missing something here i'm
missing something here so she come out
and bothering you or knocking on the
door or interrupting you and saying hey
i need you to cut the yard or hey can
you watch the baby while i go do a thing
and you're in the middle of
a project of some sort
yeah so it
this is this is kind of how the daily
routine goes um it's pretty much down to
it see
so i'll get up about four o'clock i'll
go take a shower come outside go to work
um i'm working what are you working on
thirty eight o'clock uh
i do welding and fabrication okay
so you're just cranking you're just
you're just getting it done
i'm rolling okay
and
about at 7 30 8 o'clock i go inside
help her get her daughter get our
daughter up
and then
you know i'll have me some breakfast and
come back out and that generally will
run until about 8 30 9 o'clock
at night about 10 30
uh no that's just the morning okay
10 30 she'll come out here and visit me
then i turn around i'm back in at you
know 12 o'clock eating lunch and then
she's out here multiple times throughout
the day and
i'm just
i'm trying to find that balance of hey
honey let me work or hey honey
you know i'm trying i'm in the middle of
something i can't just stop what i'm
doing and
come inside for
three hours at a time i can't just even
though i'm self-employed i can't just
not work
for an entire afternoon and go shopping
with you right
so how so how much of this do you feel
guilt and how much of this do you feel
is actual pressure
um
as far as the pressure
what do you mean
meaning
if she swings by and says hey do you
want to come you're going to run the
grocery store with us we're about to all
go
you look around and you're covered in
sweat you got your face shield on you're
in the middle of bending something and
you're like
i mean what about what's happening right
now makes you think i want to go to the
grocery store
and then you feel guilty like well i
guess i should probably be going to the
stores you know what i mean how much of
that is her just trying to reach out and
be a human and you're taking on the
burden of this versus
her saying you can never go with me why
can't you ever go you're just sitting
here all day right which one of these is
is the truth
uh for me it's more
it's more the fact that i feel like i'm
letting her down by not spending time
with her and there you go that's my work
day too a job this is
my guess is this is on you
as much if not more than is on her and i
don't say that in a negative way just
saying
you've got you're the one that's at home
and you're struggling with being there
and withholding boundaries so here's an
easy thing right outside the studio door
is a red light and there's a switch that
goes right inside and they flip it
whenever we're recording so everybody
knows not to come in here
i want you to go to home depot and
you're handy enough you can do this in
30 minutes and get a switch and a bulb
and a red bulb and put on the outside of
your shop
and when you go into work i want you to
flip it on and it's red and i want you
to sit down with her and say
when this red light's on that means i'm
unavailable
when it's off then i'm working on
something i'm sitting down i'm drawing
up i'm i'm in a position where if you
swing by i can talk to you
and then i want you to begin drawing
boundaries around your work day because
you're getting up at 4am you're working
till nighttime
and you're coming in at various moments
here and there which is confusing for
everybody
i want you to have an on time and an off
time and when you're off at whatever
time be off at whatever time and then be
fully present
most families i'm talking to across the
country are drowning from the toggling
i'm at home at the table but i'm at work
on my phone
right i'm sitting in the kitchen while
my wife's cooking but my head is
actually trying to solve a problem at
work and she's talking and i'm only
hearing half of what she's saying
and then she feels like i'm not paying
attention to her and then she
internalizes that and then she gets
frustrated then i internalize that
frustration and i get see what i'm
saying it becomes this gap so keep these
words in your mind be wherever you are
when you're in the shop turn it on and
off give yourself a work day as though
you are
um your own boss
you gotta be in the shop running and
gunning by 4 30 you get off at 7 30 for
your first hour break
and you get an hour till 8 30. and then
from 8 30 until noon you're cranking for
three and a half hours and you get from
12 to one off and then you go until six
or til five and then you're off
see what i'm saying
and then sit down with your wife and say
here's these are going to be this is
going to be my schedule
and
own what you've got to own and then let
go of the other stuff you see what i'm
saying you got to find some balance
there unless you're in a season where
you're starting your own business you're
trying to grind from scratch
because somebody yanked the wool out
from under you
and this is just a season of six months
or 18 months or two years where
man is 24 7 365 i'm just trying to build
a book of business and i'm going and i'm
going and i'm going and i'm going is
that where you are
too it
i'm in between that phase right now i'm
i'm at a crossroads as well with my
business
between either you know
taking it 100
and
just cranking this business up to what
it can be
and
or
going and
getting a day job to be able to even
qualify
for a mortgage
because self-employment is two years of
history
and i'm not trying to live in my in-laws
house for
another year and a half you can go rent
a house just fine
yeah and that's the discussion that me
and her have had and
you know what kind of areas and stuff
like that and that's
that's the other part that i'm i'm kind
of struggling with is brother but listen
don't overthink it just go run a house
that's not where you're gonna live
forever it's gonna be for six months or
it's gonna be for a year or go get a
two-bedroom apartment man it's not your
in-laws house
if you can afford it go get it done
and well what about the schools and what
about that man you got an
eight-month-old
right you'll figure out the that's
that's why we tell people to rent
because you'll find out in short order
is just a community you want to live in
or do you want to go find somewhere else
to live further away closer
and you know off top of your head
whether you want to run this business or
you want to get a job you know that
and i would tell you to quit
in either way like i don't know just
jump in and if it's going to be working
on this business
get with a crew i'll send you a couple
of books real quick um not real quick
but i'll send you a couple of books i
want you to read i'm gonna send you
entree leadership by old man by dave
ramsey and i'm to send you ken coleman's
book from paycheck to purpose it's going
to walk you through the the blueprint
for
going to get a job in a strange city
that you just in state that you just got
dropped off in
and it's going to provide you a path
towards running your own small business
either way you're gonna have to have a
road map but i'm gonna i'm gonna provide
you with either road map okay
but you just gotta pull the trigger and
go do it
when it comes to boundaries at home go
get a light and turn it on and off and
be very clear here's my new work
schedule type it out on a piece of paper
print it up let her speak into it and
then let this be this
and there's gonna be some like is he
really serious about this i don't know
what do you think
there's gonna be some awkwardness and
some i told you that's fine that's to be
expected but you're gonna live by this
work schedule right and then man guys
get your own place
it's time get your own place we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today a triple eight
loan two hundred
trust me that's triple eight loan two
hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in the miles consumer
access dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane suite 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to
uh let's see here's zach in chinatown
chicago what's up zack
oh not much how are you doing today dr
john we're just figuring it out my
brother how can i help man i'm good
well i gotta i got an issue well i guess
i don't know if it's an issue or not
that's hopefully you can help me out
with that
so my mom
she's been married three times and she
just can't seem to have a relationship
that sticks
and she just goes from boyfriend to
boyfriend she don't even
leave the one before she gets with the
other it's crazy and i have a
two-year-old and
she likes to spend time with my
two-year-old which is which is great but
the boyfriend is always around in some
way either he lives there or she has to
do something nope
i'll solve that one for you answers no
see and i always you know i'm married
but i always heard you know like with
divorces and stuff you
you should be uh careful of bringing
something new around i just didn't know
like i just didn't know if it was a huge
deal having someone eat you know because
they just visit for a couple hours or
whatever i didn't know know how to go
about that
super super direct yeah man the number
of
young women i've met with over the years
i can't even count
mom's boyfriend
step dad's
girlfriend
like the number of people who've had
negative interactions there
i mean i can't even count
so i don't know what the statistics on
that is
i don't want to overstate it
but two things are
sounding loud and clear to me number one
either you or your wife have some alarm
bells going off listen to your gut with
your comes to your kid okay
listen to your gut
number two it's as simple as
mom i love you so much
anytime you want to come over here and
be with kid that is great
i am overbearing when it comes to
um
people that i don't know interacting
with her child and so i don't want her
or him around any of your boyfriends
but honey they're just my no i'm sorry
mom i know i know it's weird and i know
it's a lot and it's probably me just
being a first-time parent that's fine um
but i don't want my baby around
anybody that we don't know and that
we're not comfortable with if you date
somebody for a long time and bring them
around and i get to know them and our
wife gets to know him and we both feel
like that person's safe then great but
that's our decision to make
it could cause drama it could cost i
will then fine you're judging me that's
all
you can't control how mom's gonna
respond what you can do is protect that
baby little girl and that's not a risk
i'm willing to take
okay so
you're saying just uh you sound
disappointed
you know six months a year down the road
whatever the case may be then it might
be okay they might not be a bad guy it's
just we have no idea yeah i don't care i
mean like it's not my job to filter
through whether this i'm just gonna say
i don't want this person in my kid's
life
and given your um like your description
of your mother's history there yeah i
don't want that in my life
you know what i mean what what is it
about the boyfriends that makes makes
you uneasy there's something that's
setting your alarms off
uh well it's just every boyfriend she's
had or husband there's always been a
problem her her first husband was was my
dad of course and they divorced before i
was
even two so i can't i can't tell you
what the problem was there but her
second husband
uh he was angry all the time always
yelling throwing things
and just just crazy situations and her
third husband same way so it's just her
judgment is always
off can i ask you a harder question i
never know what she's going to bring
home so to speak so just say
she just never had good judgment so i
wouldn't expect the next one to have
good judgment even though i don't even
know who he is i just i just got to
expect probably going to be a problem so
can i ask you a hard
question does your baby need to be
around your mom right now
you know that's
that's a good question it's not a good
question that's a simple that's a
softball question
mom is the common denominator
that's right that's right
and that's a really really hard
conversation
and i know that
yeah and i'm sorry that that's been
dropped in your lap there because the
picture of the perfect grandma that can
come by and
pick up the baby so we can me and my
wife can still go on dates all that is
so great man or just dropping the kid
off so i can go to target real quick and
home depot for a minute and clear my
head
man and the christmases and all all
those
fantasy pictures are so good
it doesn't sound like your mom's a safe
space for that baby girl right now
and it might be that grandma can see
her granddaughter around you guys
when y'all are at i mean at your house
that sounds great
and it might be that you have to set a
broad boundary like we're not letting
her go to anybody's house right now
we're we're kind of circling the wagons
a little bit for a season
you're not gonna let her come see your
grandma no no you can come over here and
see her that's fine but we're gonna keep
her here and that's gonna impact you
guys it's gonna be hard
um because it's gonna impact your dating
life and it's gonna impact your ability
to run to the store and stuff and your
daughter's worth that
is that fair yeah
yeah you're very right
i hate that for you man like just guide
a guy i hate that
and it's just so tough because
my mom literally she bought a house
two houses down for me so she could be
around that's when she was a little more
stable and now
i guess all this stuff going on in her
life she's she's never even there she
just ran off to tennessee with her new
boyfriend this week
and that's hey it's weird it's your mom
dude that's so weird i know what i mean
if you go back and listen to this call
you're talking about your mom as though
you're 48 and it's your 22 year old
daughter
which tells me you have been i feel like
it is because you have been responsible
for the emotional regulation of your mom
your whole life
and that's not your job
she's an adult
and you've been carrying it and carrying
it and carrying it in part there's a
little voice in the back number one your
wife sees it all she sees it all doesn't
she
oh yeah yes so part of this maybe you
sit now your wife saying hey you're
super right i'm sorry don't please don't
please don't bring this up in a future
fight i was wrong and we're gonna create
some boundaries here and they're your
boundaries to create cause it's your mom
um
but there's part of your body
that doesn't want your daughter having
to carry the same load that you've had
to carry
and so don't make her
and
dude i'm not for one second minimizing
this i know how hard this will be must
be the worst the worst the worst
but it's right
right
yeah it is
i'll have some extra um i'll have some
extra chips in queso 40 my brother
because i know this the whole thing will
be hard
maybe she'll sell the house in san
tennessee and make things easier but
probably not maybe tennessee's a great
place to be
you can load up the truck and move to
beverly but man
i'm sorry two houses down it's like the
it's like
you're ray romano man oh geez
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
well done kelly and jenna
today's song of the day is the fountains
of wayne classic
that's stacy's mom and it goes like this
stacy's mom has got it going on stacy
can i come over after school
we can hang around by the pool did your
mom get back from her business trip is
she there is she trying to give me the
slip you know i'm not the little boy
that i used to be i'm all grown up now
baby can't you see that stacy's mom has
got it going on she's all i want and
i've waited for so long stacy can't you
see you're not you're just not the girl
for me i know it might be wrong but i'm
in love
with stacy's mom
it's got it going on we'll see you soon
peace out
coming up on the next episode my brother
has used this opportunity to financially
exploit my mother ah gross in her will
she has left
him
the only asset she has left which is her
uh 120-acre farm why not you the boy
gets the farm what's the girl get the
plates uh the girl gets the plate yes
the girl gets pleased
gosh
why
says annelise boston dating mom's
ex-boyfriend please tell me that's not
right uh unfortunately
it is are you serious what are you doing
what happened
[Music]